vamos a hablar del potencial eléctrico b
y este es uno de los conceptos si no es
que el mayor concepto que más
confusiones causa en toda la física
primero porque suena como energía
potencial eléctrica pero no lo es es
diferente aunque está relacionada con la
energía potencial pero el potencial
eléctrico ve es diferente y bueno el
nombre no ayuda y otra razón por la que
es confuso es que el potencial eléctrico
b es un número asociado con puntos en el
espacio es solamente un número es
abstracto es una idea abstracta no
podemos tener en la mano el potencial
eléctrico b es un número abstracto
asociado con puntos en el espacio aquí
tenemos puntos en el espacio solo he
puesto círculos alrededor de puntos
vacíos en el espacio aquí en la pantalla
pero no hay nada acá estos círculos
rodean puntos vacíos en el espacio para
que podamos hablar sobre ellos
explícitamente y si por aquí no hay
ninguna carga si tuviéramos literalmente
uno
vacío el valor b en cualquier punto de
este universo sería 0 0 acá 0 allá el
número asociado con cada punto en el
espacio sería igual a 0 lo que sería
bastante aburrido e inútil que tiene que
pasar para que el valor b no sea 0 pues
vamos a poner una carga aquí ponemos una
carga positiva q en un punto de este
espacio y ahora los puntos en el espacio
alrededor de esta carga tendrán un
número de asociado diferente de 0 este
número sea más grande si estamos cerca
de esta carga kun por lo que los valores
debe por acá van a ser bastante grandes
y los valores de ve aquí lejos de la
carga van a ser más pequeños mientras
más nos alejemos más pequeños van a ser
y por qué nos interesa esto bueno la
razón por la que esto nos interesa es
que las unidades del potencial eléctrico
son jules sobre colom y esto nos da una
pista del por qué nos interesa esto los
hubs nos interesan porque son energía
cosa que tenga energía nos puede ser
útil podemos obtener trabajo de ello o
energía cinética y los giles por culo
nos dicen que si tenemos un punto por
acá y resulta que tiene unos 100 jules
por colom ese es el valor de de este
punto en el espacio lo que significa es
que recuerden que aquí no hay nada pero
si hubiera algo si por ejemplo
tuviéramos una carga positiva de 2
colones y tomáramos esta carga y la
pusiéramos en este punto vacío del
espacio antes de que la pongamos aquí el
valor b en este punto del espacio es de
100 pero cuando ponemos esta carga aquí
pues para qué nos sirve este valor de
100 bueno sabemos que el potencial
eléctrico ve en este punto es de 100
jules por culo si aquí yo pongo dos
colones puntos de energía tendremos aquí
pues vamos a tener 200 esa es la clave y
el por qué nos interesa el potencial
eléctrico b porque nos permite encontrar
la energía potencial eléctrica
que ponemos como p algunas personas usan
la letra o para describir la energía
potencial eléctrica y la fórmula es q
que es la carga que pusimos en este
punto en el espacio que en este caso fue
de 2 colom si tomamos la q que
corresponde y la multiplicamos por el
valor del potencial eléctrico b y esto
nos dice cuántos jules habrá para las
cargas en esta región esa energía
potencial eléctrica se encuentra entre
estas dos cargas de acá la carga que
creó la ve y la carga que pusimos en
este punto y esta vez es una forma
rápida de saber cuál será la energía
potencial eléctrica acá en este caso ya
que tengo dos culos aquí tomo mis dos
culos y los multiplicó por 100 jules por
colom ya que ese es el valor b y resulta
que tenemos 200 dulce energía potencial
eléctrica almacenada entre estas dos
cargas por eso es que nos interesa el
potencial eléctrico b es una forma de
calcular la energía potencial eléctrica
para una carga que sea colocada en este
punto en el espacio
que tiene este valor ve pero como
obtenemos este valor ve si yo no les
hubiera dado este dato no tendremos
forma de calcular la energía potencial
tenemos que encontrar una manera de
calcular ve para cualquier punto en el
espacio con base en la carga que los
está creando ya que es la carga quien
crea los valores ve hay una fórmula para
esto la fórmula nos dice que el
potencial eléctrico creado por una carga
es igual a k k es la constante eléctrica
es igual al 9 por 10 a la 9 newtons por
metro cuadrado sobre colom al cuadrado
ese es el valor de k no cambia y está
acá es multiplicada por la carga que va
a crear el potencial eléctrico en este
caso es esta q nuestra q positiva
cualquiera que ésta sea que crea el
valor de b esa es nuestra q si a lo
mejor aquí ponemos 5 q los positivos
vamos a encontrar la b creada por esta
carga de los cinco colores
si aquí pusiéramos 3 q los negativos
aquí encontraríamos la b que es creada
por esta carga de menos tres colores a
veces hay problemas que tienen muchas
cargas simultáneas como este de acá pero
esta q se refiere a la carga que crea el
potencial eléctrico ve no es la carga
que pusimos en ese lugar en el espacio
no son estos dos colores que pusimos
aquí y esto lo vamos a dividir entre la
distancia que hay entre esta carga y el
punto en el espacio donde quiero
calcular la ve algunas personas le
llaman a esto un radio pero a mí no me
gusta porque siento que implica que
a ver un círculo aquí y realmente no hay
un círculo esta r es la distancia que va
desde este punto en donde están la carga
que crea los valores de b hasta el punto
en el espacio en donde yo quiero conocer
el valor de b
esto es r como determinamos esto vamos a
ver algunos números digamos que la carga
que existe aquí es de un nano kulon nano
es 10 a la menos 9 así que aquí tenemos
un nano culo y digamos que la distancia
desde esta carga hasta este punto en el
espacio es digamos de 9 centímetros yo
quiero saber cuál es el valor de b vamos
a encontrar ya tenemos nuestra fórmula
esta vez va a ser igual a nuestra
constante eléctrica acá siempre va a ser
igual a 9 por 10 a la 9
newtons por metro cuadrado entre colom
al cuadrado esto lo multiplicó por mi
carga que queramos es de 10 a la menos 9
collins y lo dividimos por el valor de r
y el valor de r es de 9 centímetros pero
aquí hay que tener cuidado todo tiene
que estar en términos de metros
kilogramos o segundos cuando estamos en
física por ejemplo esta constante está
en términos de metros así que tengo que
usar metros aquí y 9 centímetros son
punto 0 9 metros y si realizo esto me va
a quedar que este 10 a la menos 9 se
cancela con este 10 a la 9 estos se van
y tengo 9 dividido entre punto 09 y nos
quedara 100 elegí este valor justamente
para tener el mismo resultado que aquí
abajo nos quedan 100 jules por colom y
ustedes me pueden decir y de dónde
salieron los giles bueno veamos las
unidades
uno de estos metros cancela a otro de
estos metros acá arriba uno de estos
colonos se cancela con el de aquí arriba
y nos quedan las unidades
newton por metros sobre colom y newton
por metro es fuerza por distancia que
son jules y es por eso que tenemos jules
por colom esto nos da el número de jules
que se van a encontrar en un punto en el
espacio por cada kilómetro de carga que
pongamos ahí y esto funciona para
cualquier punto imaginemos que elegimos
un punto que se encuentra el doble de
cerca que el anterior un punto por acá
está
r de acá es de 4.5 centímetros esto lo
divido entre r y como no extraer es la
mitad de grande este punto de acá tendrá
un valor de de 200 jules por colom y
mientras más me acerque si yo me acerco
aún más por ejemplo a un punto que se
encuentre a tres centímetros de
distancia
esto es una tercera parte de esta otra
distancia así que voy a dividir esto
entre una tercera parte de la distancia
por lo que voy a obtener el triple del
resultado esto no está al cuadrado es
simplemente r por lo que este valor b
será de 300 hills por colom esto me dice
que si yo quiero tener un punto con
muchísima energía potencial debería
poner esta cosa muy cercana a esta carga
y esto me daría mucho más energía
potencial a quien no sería tanta y aquí
mucho menos mientras más la aleje menos
energía potencial tendré y no habrá
energía potencial eléctrica a menos que
ponga una tarea sólo habrá el potencial
eléctrico hasta que ponga otra
carga en esta región otra que esté
relacionada otra carga además de la
carga que me genera mis valores ve en
este momento tendremos energía potencial
y con esta fórmula podremos calcular la
q por la vez que obtuvimos en este punto
en el espacio hay que tener cuidado
porque a veces las personas se descuidan
y ve se parece al ave que usamos como
voltaje usamos be para el potencial
eléctrico y también lo usamos para el
voltaje cuál es la diferencia acaso son
lo mismo pues no no del todo a veces
podríamos tratarlos como si fueran lo
mismo y no tenemos problema pero a veces
si podemos tener problemas si los
tratamos igual el voltaje técnicamente
es un cambio en la energía potencial
entre dos puntos esa es la diferencia en
el potencial eléctrico entre dos puntos
en el espacio y aunque tienen las mismas
unidades porque el cambio en el
potencial eléctrico seguirá teniendo
como unidades jules por culo solamente
que como este es un cambio a esto le
damos un nuevo nombre
a la unidad de jules por colom le
llamamos volt jules por colom es volt
pero el voltaje se refiere a una
diferencia en el potencial eléctrico a
qué me refiero con esto bueno por
ejemplo este punto es de 300 jules por
colom en este punto de acá tenemos 100
jules por culo si yo calculo la delta ve
que hay entre estos dos puntos y
quisiera ver cuál es la diferencia en b
la diferencia sería de 200 soles por
culo esto significa el voltaje entre
estos dos puntos en el espacio 200 volts
esto es lo que significa es la
diferencia en el potencial eléctrico
entre dos puntos en el espacio cuando
hablamos solamente del potencial
eléctrico en un punto en el espacio
entonces le llamamos potencial eléctrico
y es así como están relacionados